hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
supernatural Castiel is back and he is
nuking taquitos at the gas and sip while
an angel is nuking people are nuking
pain that is in a pink cloud of
pepto-bismol we also learned that
Metatron spell is irreversible and
Crowley and Abaddon face off over the
phone so let's talk about our favorite
moments and then I'll do my review so
biggest thing I think the Crowley was
totally telling the truth Metatron spell
is totally irreversible but that does
not mean that there is not another way
to restore heaven to Castiel new
Kentucky dose of the gas and sip so the
romance subplot here was really funny as
well as him kind of miming human
behavior but didn't you get the vibe at
the end of the episode the Castiel is
going to open up his own angel tech
support hotline at some point he's so
concerned with helping angels adapt to
life on earth that I think he's going to
start helping people actively and will
build his own following of angels
remember on the other side of that coin
Bartholomew has his own faction of
angels trying to take over the earth cut
straight to hell so Crowley and Abaddon
face off on the phone we haven't seen
Abaddon and a few episodes so we don't
really know what she's been up to but we
do know that Crowley is losing support
oh the indignity of being put on hold in
your own kingdom that moment at the end
of the episode with Crowley he basically
stolen a syringe and was secretly
talking to someone I think he's just
trying to find out who's still loyal to
him he's not gonna be in that chair
forever though he does to mark shepard
for doing so much was so little he's
been in that chair all season but now
for the fun stuff Dean's dating tips I
feel like I should do a video just for
Dean's dating tips like Dean's best
dating tips whenever the show goes on
break for the winter usually my dates
end after I run out of singles and
Ephraim's pink pain reliever raise your
hand if you felt bad whenever he started
new key people and it looked like
pepto-bismol don't feel bad they didn't
feel a thing and then there's all the
Castiel moments in this episode list
your favorites in the comments below but
there's the coffee stirrer there's the
rose there's the dating advice
then there's the baby he was humming the
tune from Greatest American Hero
I can't hum it right here cuz of my
video we get taken down but just humming
in your heads it's so hilarious next
week is a riff on the omen movie series
they investigate a boy who basically has
control over dead spirits be sure to
subscribe to get my video but what did I
think of the episode overall well I give
it a solid beat I always love Castiel
episodes like I said before those are
some of the best episodes ever the
coffee stir all the Castiel moments they
were great but I would have liked to see
more crap
I feel like they basically put him in
that chair and they really haven't been
using him a lot it's a real testament to
mark Shepards ability as an actor that
he's able to do so much with so little
don't worry he won't be in this chair
forever
they're basically seating in a skate
plot so I think before the mid-season
finale he'll actually break out isn't it
funny how Crowley and Castiel are
basically in the same boat this season
they basically started at the top
respectively depending on which
perspective you're looking at and fell
straight to the bottom but let me know
what your favorite moments were right
now on the show I feel like Castiel and
Crowley are the two most interesting
characters obviously Dean has the best
dating advice ever
and Sam keel is pretty good too
obviously we didn't see Ezekiel in this
episode but right now I feel like he's
not the most interesting character on
the show in other news tonight there's a
new episode of arrow so be sure to
subscribe to get my video I'll post it
right after the episode airs I'll also
post the rest of my upload schedule for
the rest of this week in the comments so
check it out I've got a bunch of videos
coming all the way through Sunday if you
really want to help me out please
like and share this video using the
tools below it really helps me out thank
you so much click here to learn all
about Supernatural this season and click
here to learn all about the special
Doctor Who videos I'm doing for the 50th
anniversary I've got a bunch of stuff
coming in the next two weeks and I'm
doing a giveaway thank you so much for
watching see you guys tonight
high fives
you